hello and welcome everyone this is the
active inference live stream it is act
INF live stream 8.2 and it is November
17th 2020 so welcome everyone listeners
and participants welcome to teamc
everyone we are an experiment in online
team communication learning and practice
related to active inference you can find
us at our website our Twitter our email
on our public keybase team or on YouTube
this is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please do provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work all backgrounds and perspectives
are welcome here in learning about these
questions and as far as video etiquette
for live streams goes just remember to
mute if there's noise in the background
and raise your hands so we can hear from
everyone on the stack use respectful
speech Behavior Etc ET today in exciting
act imp stream 8.2 we are going to have
introductions and warm-ups and then we
will at whatever rate makes sense
welcome Shannon we will walk through the
sections of 8.2 as with 8.0 and 8.1 we
are going to be discussing the paper
scaling active inference by chance at
all 2019 and Alec thanks so much for
coming on to the show today we're going
to talk about the goals and the road map
of the paper hopefully from the author's
perspective we'll then have a little
pause just for an open Q&A because
there's a lot of different directions
this paper can take one so we'll just
pause there and then we'll continue
through the figures just two of them and
just address a few different domains of
follow-up questions about the paper and
then if we want to slash still have time
we can go through some of the notation
and math again for the rest of 2020 we
are going to be moving into papers 9 10
and 11 so check it out on Twitter
paper nine is going to be about
Consciousness paper 10 is about scripts
and about social interactions and paper
11 is about um modeling under the
sophisticated effective inference
framework for the intros and warm-ups if
everyone could just introduce their name
and their location whatever else they'd
like to State especially our firsttime
guests and then just pass to somebody
who has not spoken so all start I'm
Daniel I'm in California
and I will pass it to
Alec hey everyone yeah I'm Alec chance
I'm based in Brighton um final year PhD
student at susex and thanks for having
me on the
stream we will go to um
Sasha hi uh my name is Sasha I'm also a
graduate student and I'm based out of
David
California I will pass it to
Sten Stephen you're unmuted but um it
doesn't have any sound maybe just reload
and temporarily let's just go to
Shannon hi guys I'm Shannon
I'm based at the University California
in Merced but currently in South Dakota
I'll pass it to
Blue hi I'm blue Knight I am an
independent research consultant and I am
based out of New Mexico I will pass it
to
Alex hi my name is Alex I'm in Moscow
Russia and I'm a researcher and systems
management school and they pass it to
Ian hi my name is
isan I'm in Russia Moscow and I pass it
to uh Steven Steven are you here I'm
gonna try again does that work yes yep
okay hi I'm Stephen I'm based in Toronto
I'm actually studying a practice-based
PhD through Canter Christ Church
University in the UK and I'm pleased to
be
here hi I'm Mel Andrews um and I'm in
Cincinnati doing a
PhD cool lot of different stages and
areas so it will be a great discussion
to bring to the technical side with this
paper for the warm-up questions people
can just raise their hand as they'd like
to speak and I will just put up the
first two questions they are for today's
discussion what is something that you
are excited about and then the second
question is what is a question you're
wondering about
so while people are thinking about it or
raising their hand one question I was
wondering about was how do we trade off
between explore and exploit in the two
figures we saw examples of explore or
exploit but what is required to enact
something that is able to mediate
between the two of them or find a
compromise between those two
strategies anyone have any thoughts or
want to raise their hand
Stephen yeah I'm also excited about the
explore um and the exploit side as well
to be honest because I think that opens
up um a big shift in the way that we
socially interact and the way that we
organize ourselves so trying to look at
a real foundational way to sort of
approach that is going to be quite
helpful I think in a lot of fields of
practice cool Alec and then anyone else
who raises their
hand yeah am I unmuted or muted sound
good sound good yeah uh I just wanted to
comment on your comment um because I I'm
also very interested in that but I guess
I'll go on the record saying that I'm
not not convinced that active inference
provides sometimes it said to provide a
solution for the explore explo dilemma I
I don't think it does uh I think it re
recasts it so you know now it's not a
question of
balancing exploration exploitation but
they're both zoomed into this different
objective function but in
practice
uh there there isn't a sort of magic
balancing act that you you get out of
this um so I think it's a good way to
recast the exploration expectation D but
certainly not a solution to the problem
awesome
blue so I kind of have like a tangential
question I and thank you Alec for your
comments because it just plays right
into I think what's missing very clear
that um if the environment is
homogeneous there's no real need for
exploration because the agent is not
going to gain any you know any
additional progress by exploring the
environment but I I just wonder where
autonomy factors in right like so you
know some agents have more or less
control over their environment and
there's no like real room for this or
not that I've seen anyway in in the um
active inference framework like where
the differing levels of autonomy of the
agent play into the need to explore
versus
exploit cool good question
Stephen yeah I think that that point
about how to look at the agent starts to
bring in the enactive component a lot
more I think and the generative model
that's kind of sitting inside the person
and existential kind of sense making so
I think that's that also yeah it's like
pushing this back from a a real world
perspective and saying okay maybe we
need to work back the other way from
complex multisensory experiences towards
active inference as well as using active
inference to do modeling of maybe kind
of very clean sort of low
dimensional approaches it's like should
we also be coming back from the other
direction um and I did I've got an
activity called conceptual action
sociometry an activity where people move
around space to understand how their
orientation is during a moment of
encounter and I've asked people to
unpack it in terms of the three
different areas of active influence the
sort of pragmatic gain epistemic
foraging or or risk mitigation or
salience and it's actually really
interesting when they break it down that
way and start to think about what was I
trying to do but from that kind of high
dimensional kind of synthesis of being
in a really immersive moment and they it
actually people seem to who don't know
anything about active inference actually
were quite intuitively seeing quite a
lot of shifts in those three different
areas of focus depending on the type of
um event or moment that they were
reflecting on because they were going
back to an event and thinking about the
focus of their attention at that
particular moment in time and how much
were they sort of bringing these three
areas in and then I suppose between that
you could infer something about the
exploration sort of desire to learn or
the exploitation gain but I I agree I
think it does depend on the moment
that's in question so yeah I'm there's a
few things that kind of this is sort of
tapping into which I'm really interested
in cool and to tie that just together
with a recast idea from Alec it's um
kind of like nature nurture explore
exploit people don't know about these
bin Aries they're not natural kinds
until they're taught them and then the
resolution to these kinds of dichotomies
or binaries false or not is not some
parameter that varies from zero to one
that trades off for example when Evelyn
Fox Keller was moving beyond nature and
nurture it's the Mirage of a space
between it's about reconsidering the
situation so that there doesn't have to
be something like a bipartition so
that's definitely the direction that we
will try to take it because it's a
really cool idea the second or I guess
the last warm-up question is is and On a
related note what would be an
interesting control system or any system
to model with active inference so we're
going to go into like a trolley car and
a um Hopper I guess and a pendulum and I
think it will be fun to hear about those
but um we heard about this the social
and the spatial there's questions that
we've raised about biology communication
anything else that somebody wants to
bring up or whether it's yeah Mel please
and then Sasha
yeah um so I'm what I'm excited about
I'm really excited
about uh this kind of work um as I'm a
I'm a philosopher but um with this sort
of stuff the AC inference fup stuff I'm
like please stop theorizing just like
let's let's play with
this um so I'm really excited about this
kind of work and um the question that's
motivating me is is really sort of
figuring out um
what the boundaries of these various
models are so so what the boundaries of
of active inance are relative to the
free energy principle and then relative
to EG predictive coding models and that
sort of thing
um someone brought up recently on
Twitter I guess uh it there's a there's
a biologist at my University um who's
doing really kind of groundbreaking work
in in in like perception cognition um
perceptual cognition and stuff um
in I guess butterflies but mostly uh
jumping spiders Sal um so the the
morouse lab Nate more house is doing for
example um salti had like very uh
elaborate like um mating dances and
things and and they're signaling to each
other um and they're doing stuff like
like the evolution of color perception
in in these jumping spiders um it's
really fascinating work and they
mentioned recently um or Nate mentioned
recently that um that the lab is doing
some like simulation work on on how we
evolve additional color per set um so so
you can right you can you can if you
have uh certain like genes and proteins
for for um pursuing certain colors you
can you can kind of like shift the
probility distribution the the the range
of of color that those pick up right um
that's something that that Evolution can
kind
of modulate but um the evolution of an
entirely different um an entirely new
color percept is is something different
um and
so they're doing some some like in
silico work on that and I I thought yeah
that's what that's what active INF
that's exactly what active INF should be
do that's what we should be doing it's
great so I think that's what we should
be striving for thanks for that very
interesting summary Sasha and then
anyone else um thank you Mel for
bringing up the jumping spiders um they
have incredible eyes you should all look
it up um but I uh I'm interested in this
um from a developmental perspective and
what active inference can contribute to
um how systems develop and communicate
and specifically uh humans um how our
Ino environment and the activity um of
that process um shapes the development
of the human um and kind of on a more
broad scale um how this can play into
teaching and how active inference can be
applied in the classroom at different
educational levels but in a way that um
sets up the environment such that agents
are uh encouraged to explore instead of
being dragged through the material as uh
students often
are so that's that's my curiosity in
this time
theot cool yes lot of otsky
fans
slash colleagues through through time on
this discussion any other
comments but really great points there
about like the evolution and the
development of perception and then at
the level that we can at least
experience or enact agency can we choose
to see a color as different can you look
at that ambiguous pattern and choose to
see it one way or another can we
understand uh many of these perceptive
questions as being related to maybe not
simply explore exploit maybe having an
element of multiscale agency I think
there a lot of ways that that could play
out in people's life while also
recognizing that we're not talking about
just metaphors here or narratives we're
also talking about this specific
framework with the paper that we're
going to discuss now so let's talk about
those details but then maybe you know we
can dip back to the other systems but
let's think about how this paper and
also our special time with Alec will
help us understand these broader
questions at least where we want to go
after this short discussion so the paper
scaling active inference we read the
goal last time um Alec maybe if you
could just however you want to or
however long just what what were you
setting out to do or how did the
collaboration come to be what were you
asking before how did you get to this
paper and this
goal um so I guess historically the sort
of historic uh lead up to the paper was
just very interested in reinforcement
learning machine learning and also very
interested in active inference so there
a those sort of uh a natural overlap but
in terms of the motivation I
think the two communities don't really
speak to each other as much as they
should and so much of the work that's
happening in reinforcement learning um
especially modelbased reinforcement
learning has direct analogies to the
work that's being developed in the
active inference Community um so stuff
like the of variational methods
variational Auto encoders the use of
Dynamics models the use of trajectory
based planning uh or just planning in
general and these algorithms have a lot
of similarities between the two um the
use of intrinsic objectives these
Information Gain terms is widespread and
both the use of belief based planning so
all the things that we sort of touched
on in the paper so in my mind when I
started out the the aim was really just
to construct an agent using the
Machinery that would be common and um
relatable to the machine learning crowd
but that was consistent with the active
influence very much um and I guess a
secondary goal was
also to put together an initial attempt
to look at
whether what needs to be put in to get
some of these ideas to scale um uh with
a particular focus on you know this
wasn't a biologically
plausible suggestion but looking at some
of the objective functions the expected
free energy at scale
um I think is of interest rather than
you know where it's commonly looked at
in these smallet scet uh TM sty
environment cool really helpful in a lot
of terms that we've heard but to link
together the ideas of the variational
inference with the belief and the
trajectory based planning those are all
really cool things I just have a
question about the at scale part so one
aspect was that you introduced The
Continuous State space as opposed to the
discret but is there anything else
that's meant by at scale or what what
does it mean to scale in this
context well I mean
so I
guess
the scale just means is almost defined
in relation to what is currently uh
common in the active influence
literature which is where your entire
world is often designed by four or five
stat
um and there's transitions for so this
paper um presents a framework that can
be applied to you know observations of
um you know 10,000 100,000 uh and so
your state space or your observation
space is much larger um so that's what I
meant by by scale is is putting forward
a framework that could be applied to
high dimensional tasks and the ones that
we currently consider and there's also a
second thing which is not really
captured in the word scale but also the
complexity of the Dynamics um so some of
these tasks actually have quite a small
state space you know four or five but
the complexity of their Dynamics
requires um large models of a number of
parameters to them um so there's kind of
a scating aspect and a scating in in the
space of complexity
of cool very interesting stuff and at
any point people can just raise their
hand but I think we can keep on walking
through these areas and last time we did
walk through the different areas in the
road map just how we introduce active
inference and the current state and then
walk through the specifics of the model
show some proof of concept experiments
relate to previous work and then discuss
and conclude with some of these
sentiments related to what Alec is
saying and I also found it interesting
there's the scaling dimensionality then
there's the introduction of continuous
State spaces not just discreet and then
often as machine learning people might
use the word scaling to mean it's about
the number of observations the size of
the data set um and that relates to like
the compute scaling relationship as you
add uh when you double the data set
input is it the same amount of training
time is it twice as long is it four
times as long is it 4,000 times as long
and um so really interesting because
there's also the scaling in terms of the
understanding in the world world and
people talk about scaling in innovation
in entrepreneurship and how do you scale
a solution so there's a lot of parallel
meanings and a fun and concise title
because uh you know that the finding
isn't going to be in the title there
isn't just a simple way that says oh
this protein does this in this species
we're talking about developments in a
modeling framework but we also want to
be specific about what those advances
are and how they relate to systems so
maybe just on the road map Alec or
anyone else just anything to say about
it or why was it arranged this way
personally I was just kind of wondering
why the previous work is at the end is
that a difference in our um academic
conventions or is that just because it
was more results
oriented yeah I mean you don't get a lot
of leeway in machine learning sty papers
um pre I mean previous work can I go
after the introduction or uh at the end
but it's always you know introduction
some methods of presenting a model
normally quite short test when the
experiments previous section very short
discussion that's kind of standed across
the field but um the reason I think I
chose prev the end was just because I
discussed active inference which
naturally leads in from the introduction
and that introduces a little bit of mass
which then naturally flows into the mod
like a previous work might have broken
up that
flow a little bit but more L cool um
makes sense um I think we can
walk through the next sections so right
now we're in the just open pause for
questions I have a few written down just
as far as just big questions because
we're trying to be a bridge in this
discussion and through our conversation
between those who might be hearing about
active inference for the first time but
they're coming from machine learning
thinking about how cool methods perhaps
with philosophical implications might be
utilized and there's also a lot of
people who are in the active inference
side of things or the in activism side
or the philosophy side where the details
of the machine learning might be their
first time hearing about it so how will
we just come from where we are and think
about what questions and what kinds of
fun things to talk about will make that
bridge Stephen first and then anyone who
wants
to yeah I'm I'm just curious because I
know that the scaling question has been
maybe looked at more from a
philosophical perspective in the kind of
active inference so what this paper
really helped me do or helped me was it
like broke that fear of questioning the
kind of these models because the like
people like yourself and um annel and
that are saying look there's a challenge
here in the scaling like this stuff is
being kind of used at these
low-dimensional spaces and basically it
showed like a gap in the literature in
terms of how to action that which kind
of helped me because it sort of gave me
a bit of permission to say okay it's
okay there's a gap there and it's not
that I just don't understand everything
it's just not easy to scale and I think
this paper was the first one to
explicitly say that because all the
other papers tended to talk about yes we
know how to scale but in a philosophical
way but this is like okay well this is
the problem from a a practice
perspective cool just one note on that
if anyone else want raise their hand I
really love this idea where there's the
Gap in the literature and there's
there's a billion gaps on the literature
um it's about which ones are Salient and
fundable and relevant so there's many
gaps in literature and then when we find
that gap which is often very Niche like
in a PhD and I thought wow this data set
has been collected from this ant species
but not this other ant species there's a
gap in literature we don't have this
data set on this ant species and then
seeing that as a opportunity and
something that's okay even if it's not
your additional field of study it's okay
because you're at the edge like at the
Gap with us talking to the author and
talking through the equations but this
is what it looks like to look across the
Gap and try to connect because somebody
else has identified it as a research
question or maybe you have
Alec yeah I just wanted to comment on
that as well and entirely agree with
what you're saying um to come to maybe
the defense of uh the existing
literature on Act I think it's viewed a
little bit or this maybe is just me
interpreting what they're saying but um
that maybe that the problems that
they're um testing their agents in for
instance something like the teamas are
actually viewed uh as quite complex in a
different dimensions so a lot of these
reinforcement learning tasks stuff like
Atari uh most of Atari most of you know
stuff where you're already pushing to
get state-of-the-art results with huge
amount of compute and Deep Mind
competing against there they're often
you can often get by with just this
model free reinforcement learning that
doesn't require any notion of beliefs or
any notion of proper epistemics you can
get away with under exposion so what I
think uh the active influence Community
has tried to do is look at simple tasks
such as the teamas that actually well
you can solve them with beliefs but are
far far more amable to being solved with
a belief based scheme and with this
directed uh expiration and uncertainty
reduction um to show the kind of
complexity that the framework can come
up but then you could also respond by
saying that this is also thought about a
lot in reinforcement learning and uh
there is the question obviously of
whether the kind of uh process varies
they put forward will apply when you've
got uh when you've really got the scale
that reinforcement learning TS to do
yeah let let me add on to that because
it's a really great point so a lot of
times what's perceived as Cutting Edge
or modern or Advanced research in
machine learning I mean go check go
check the lay media and it's going to be
about this many graphical processors or
this size of data set or this accuracy
or this level of skill using massive
data and it's very much on the
performance end and on the eing out a
little bit more performance from
increasingly large data sets with
increasingly um large types of models um
but but it's actually in some sense a
local exploration it's locally exploring
certain Frameworks and ways of doing
machine learning which is just computer
statistics and so what this is like with
this paper is a return to Simplicity and
it's a return to a slightly different
way of conceptualizing some of the
parameters and how they're related and
the Big Data just train it bigger train
it uh better is kind of like thinking
that we can do X without a belief we can
train on go just by watching go and we
can train the L of physics just by
watching physics we can learn language
by just watching regularities in human
language these approaches um there's
Merit to them this isn't just about one
way being better it's just that what is
being done in this paper is to take the
free energy principle and AC of
inference which previously had made
these kinds of philosophically at the
very least tantalizing claims like the
relevance of a belief guided trajectory
based optimization and search taking
these very fascinating ideas a little
bit out of the sandbox into the next
level of the playground where now we can
actually start to compete or at least
compare and contrast directly with the
kinds of benchmarking algorithms that
are used so maybe one day you know
active inference go or active inference
chess but today we have the simple
control theory parameters which is one
level closer to these kinds of use cases
that are happening today one level
closer than the te-as or the the
three-state uh decision is it a mouse or
a hawk or a cat that type of
stuff cool just the questions that I put
up just thinking about how can we
continue to deepen our understanding
which we'll move on from but just like
what's something you wondered about just
always stick with that and anyone can
raise your hand well what's something
you learned about while studying the
paper whether it was something that they
wrote specifically or whether it was
something that you kind of went down a
rabbit hole and started studying about
definitely that happened for me and then
lastly like what's something your
motivating to do more or um learn about
now that you've read this paper and have
this discussion yeah Mel thanks and then
anyone
else yeah I I guess I just wanted to
jump on that and say that um I'm I'm
used to seeing people sort
of try to compare um reinforcement
learning with with act entrance or or um
related approaches and it's nice to see
something more that's more of a a
synthesis there
cool yes so I think that if there's any
other thoughts feel free but we'll look
again over the experiments and then
we'll sort of work kind of in and out
about broader topics but let's try to
understand what was really done because
this also is the point of contact with
people who might be very familiar with
machine learning and optimization
control theory but for them it might be
the first time hearing active inference
so where's the common train stop where
we're on board with the machine Learning
Community they're interested in these
kinds of tasks they frame it as explore
exploit and as we've been talking about
maybe there's like a bit of a
re-imagination or a reconceptualization
of this relationship explore un exploit
or what of these variables that's what
we want to get to at the end so let's
for sure remember that but for now let's
think about being in common with
benchmarking different data sets and
different machine learning algorithms so
so maybe we could talk about explore and
exploit how these communities think
about these and maybe your observations
about how they're different Alec in
terms of first the example that you
chose to highlight as explore so maybe
tell us about the mountain car and then
when you tell me I'll go to the figure
one but like what is this what does it
have to do with exploring what does the
machine Learning Community think about
it how does active inference apply like
what is happening
here yeah so Mountain car's quite an
interesting one um it seems so simple
it's two when you do it in a fully
observed environment there's two states
one action uh this is the continuous
version so it's continuous actions so
you know it's like the simplest task
that machine learning people present in
papers but it's actually one of the
hardest so um you know dqn vanilla dqn
doesn't stand a chance of solving this
what is dqn sorry
uh d q networks have to remember uh so
that's taking like the old um the old
idea of Q learning which is kind of was
the biggest idea of reinforcement
learning before this whole deep phase
and just uh amending with deep networks
it's the one that
um
be
Atari uh yeah the first like Deep Mind
nature I can't remember the details but
it was It was kind of the the birth of
the deep reinforcement moment great so
that one has challenges on here and then
just continue I mean basically the
reason is is because you only get a
reward when you reach that um flag up at
the top and before that your um you know
that takes about 180 steps or 180
actions that you have to um string
together before you get any notion of um
reward so just pure reward-based
schemes uh really struggle with this
they essentially have to do more or less
random actions until you get um out of
the Hill um so yeah it's it's a struggle
and that's why it's kind of exemplifies
exploration because you need to care
about learning about the
Dynamics um or some other intrinsic
quantity if you want a chance at finding
out how to solve this
PA cool very interesting blue this is
just really reminding me of a lot of
what we've talked about with explore
exploit a lot of the perspectives you've
brought about how exploring how and when
and where does it matter so pretty
interesting to hear Alec just how you
phrase that and and also just like to
hear that it's 180 sequences of actions
so this is not like control theory like
Connect Four this is like walking you
know who knows how many degrees of
freedom there are but this is many tasks
that have to get strung together in Long
sequences and then you said something
about how um it has to learn something
intrinsic for example the relationship
between its velocity position and policy
a little bit more nuanced Nexus of
action rather than just learning like
simply whether you know go means fast
and stop means slow Stephen and then
anyone else yeah can I just ask the
question about that when you say
stringing together um actions because I
I kind of had this feeling that it was
kind of a case of like you keep it the
by by there being a desire to explore in
itself through free energy that the car
realized that it could go up the other
side of the Hill further because it
could just have a reason for going there
because of Trying to minimize the desire
to free energy around exploration and in
doing so it gets that extra kind of
momentum to get up the other side of the
hill but I haven't really g into a
detail so I was just wondering how this
kind of sequence of steps and maybe just
finding yourself far up far enough up
the other Hill to get enough potential
energy just to go down and up and make
it to the flag I wonder how those two
sort of
relate great question Al maybe if you
have a thought on that yeah yeah so I
think your intuition is mostly correct
so how it plays out is that this agent
is evaluating different sequences of
actions some of those actions are going
to keep it where it's already been which
is at the bottom of this hill uh and
then some of the actions are going to
take it into a place where it's
uncertain about the
outcome um and that UNC and that
uncertainty is essentially valued by the
agent it wants to resolve it
so it's going to say okay what happens
if I do a little because it has to go
left up the hill I should have mentioned
that before it has to go left up the
hill actually actually go away from the
flag to gain momentum to around so it's
going to you know it's never gone left
up the hill and then
accelerated um doesn't know what's going
to happen when it does that that's
valuable to it in terms of epistemics
and then it realizes oh wow up the
hill yeah let me let me link that um to
the question the sequence of of
so imagine if you were going to do a
control theory optimization on shooting
a a bow and arrow so shooting a bow um
is a complex motor movement uses
probably many joints there's a lot of
you could do different speeds different
ratios it's going to be dependent on the
bow just like this is going to be
dependent on the slope and the car so
it's it's an enacted affordance that
you're trying to develop an action
sequence for and your action sequence in
uh game is often just one stepper Drop
The Connect Four token here I'll
re-evaluate after I see what they do but
if you're going to be evaluating
prospectively an action sequence in the
world it often has depth so it's like
getting out of my chair shooting the bow
there State spaces are very there's
multi- um joint so it's multi uh
dimensional and it's continuous so
that's why the multi-dimensional and the
continuous are so important and then the
depth through time is so important
because you can't just be doing a get
out of my chair or a uh shoot the bow
and arrow short-term One Step
optimization
there's no opponent for you to then take
a look at their move like in a chess
Checkers go Paradigm or even a video
game Paradigm to some extent this is
something about planning in an enormous
State space and thinking really
constructively about these intrinsic
relationships so in the bow example you
might be attuning to the tension between
the propri reception and your shoulder
and how tense the bow is to know if
you're at the end of your range of mo
movement or the bow is and if you
trained on one that was half size and
then you go to a larger one or if your
arm is hurting that day or all these
differences differences in our abilities
these things all become enacted in the
relationships that we're learning about
the intrinsic variables so in the depth
through time in intrinsic variables if
you learn that hey if I actually reverse
and start accelerating downhill a 100
times steps later it's just better like
if I go to sleep at this time 100 times
steps later it's just better and so
these allow for very nonlinear policies
to be selected because there can be
temporal depth that's learned as a
function of the actual physics basically
of the setting not just like
counterfactual you know if 13 moves down
the row this person does this with my
Rook that still is in a very if then
context and this is taking it into a
totally different domain with a
proactive action selection
policies yep so that's why this is such
an interesting paper and approach and
like again a branching off point that's
why it's foundational in the machine
learning because just like Alec
described like if deep Q learning cannot
accomplish this task then yeah it's all
great to be a human at chess or go but
if that algorithm or even that
architecture can't defeat this challenge
then we're developing something that's
incredibly specific which is great we
should have good map routing algorithms
and things like that but we're
definitely going hyperlocal down a
rabbit hole if it can't solve this but
it can solve go I don't know if it is
that case um a machine learning person
would be really welcome to help fill us
in on some of these details but that's
the kind of stuff that is um interesting
and and broached in this topic so just
to see what that looks like empirically
like the first 100 epochs um are plotted
in terms of the state space coverage
which here is just the position on the
x- axis and then the velocity on the Y
and the flag is at 0. five right Alec
like the Flag represents being at
position of point five but yeah continue
from here just anything you want to add
on figure one or what what does this
mean what is happening here I guess no
your description great the flag's not
at0 five the flag's uh what is it oh
yeah 0 five yeah uh but I just kind of
want to um self deprecate myself and say
that these results kind of they're not I
mean they're not bad the result but um
we had a follow-up paper where we got
this all working properly um called
reinforcement for inference um which is
very similar but we use a
slightly I can discuss the differences I
think they're interesting if we want but
uh just that the the results are so much
more impressive we can still uh it's
kind of both uh hitting on this and also
um here's the to advertise that that
work so in that work oh yeah if you can
actually just show the figure and that
we can sh so there it can solve the
mountain car in a single trial
and I have also the sort of State space
spots that look a bit better so here's
the so just one yeah so if you kind of
go yeah I wish had the video it can just
the first time it goes into the ring it
just solves it straight away which is
much nicer so the other the other one in
the paper that we're looking at today um
so the here it's being solved every time
that it does it and it just con gets
out and we try some harder tasks in this
like the half G2 and ant maze coverage
gotta love
it um yeah I guess that was just a I
wanted to highlight that um it can do a
lot better than this um but I'll be
happy to discuss the differences because
it's just one part of the architecture
that sure yeah what takes us from here
to what we just sort of peaked into in
this paper like what was the one thing
that you added or changed yeah so when I
wrote the original one to um so to get
this kind of
what what Carl calls parameter uh
exploration or parameter Information
Gain it's essentially you're trying to
reduce on certainty not about what's out
there in the world but about your own
model you have beliefs about um your
model uh and it's kind of in a sense is
you know what you don't know and to get
that you have to have a
distribution over your model and in this
case our model is a neural network to
need a distribution over your neural
network there's two ways is in the
literature to do this in the first paper
scaling active inference we tried B in
your networks uh there may be more
principled you know you're actually
using variation inference to estimate
this um distribution of each of your
parameters but uh in
practice they don't work nearly as well
as what we tried in the next paper uh
which is called The Ensemble approach uh
and the idea there is you just take in
this case 2 Dynamics models and train
them on different batches of the data
and that's kind of like a proxy for a
nonparametric Bas in posterior over the
um Dynamics model um you can do a little
people are kind of working out how close
it is to actually proper Bas and beliefs
but um you definitely get a notion of
uncertainty there so
here um and there's lots of interesting
reasons as to
why principles reasons as to why
Ensemble models would work better than
um bin models it's also
easier in practice to estimate stuff
like um information game
um so that just turned out to be 100
times better and in the machine Learning
Community people generally find more
success more success with uh deep
ensembles for both um uncertainty
calibration and directed
explation that's very cool thanks for
the great explanation there and so just
to sort of rehash that or say it a
little differently the approach that was
taken in this scaling active inference
paper to estimating some of these
essential parameters was done with the
basian neural network which Alec just
described it's like one way to do it it
might be a way that interfaces pretty
cleanly with a lot of other software
packages or approaches but it's the
skeleton of the model and that's the
diagram and then we think about how can
we improve it and so One Direction is
more analytical or more principled as
you described it and that's like the
fully basian sort of specifying every
little uh hidden State and that approach
can provide some interesting Avenues at
times but an approach that is also
relatively easy to implement from a
programmatic interface level and also
makes a relative minimum of assumptions
about the specific mechanics of the
system is this Ensemble or deep Ensemble
approach so the Deep adjective is just
meaning you're going to have like a
multiscale or I mean a multi- level
neural network with hidden layers or
it's just going to be deep and modern
but it's kind of like just an adjective
The Ensemble approach is describing
having a bunch of different models that
are going to be trained up on the same
or different parts of the data set and
then you could look at the average of
The Ensemble or you could look at some
other weighted combination of the
ensemble's performance and so it's
almost like Bridging the Gap from
Individual testing that's like the
single model testing to Now The Ensemble
approach is like we're going to have a
classroom and then the best answer from
R9 group all working on it independently
the best one will push forward or will
average and then even another level
beyond that is like the truly emergence
which is actually what the ants are
doing where the Ensemble works as an
ensemble in a way that is itself shaped
by development and learning and
evolution so right now The Ensemble
modeling is still like sort of well if
you just split it up into many parts you
can cover more State space you might be
able to train the model in parallel you
might make sure that no single model
over gener izes there's so many benefits
that come simply from batching and
Ensemble modeling that go beyond just
saying well what's the best single model
or what's the best um parameter range in
this type of model The Ensemble can
consist of a single type with a
different parameters between the
different Ensemble mates or they can be
heterogeneous in some aspect so just
really cool you went with what was
implementable and a common Point of
Departure with machine learning
community and the basian neural network
kind of peaks in one direction towards
more analytical more principled fully
basian approach and then on the other
side to Modern approaches in machine
learning like deep Ensemble
learning cool let's look at figure two
and what is conveyed here so this is the
hopper task oh we'll go Blue first go
ahead sorry I didn't see that can you
back up to the last figure let's do blue
and then me and then anyone else so um I
just wanted to ask and this is kind of
related to the next
figure but um I just wanted to ask that
uh when you did the hopper task and the
um pendulum so I know that that was only
based on the extrinsic value like part
of the free energy equation so like you
left off the exploration because like
exploration probably had no value in in
that problem I mean I'm assuming there
but I I was wondering here like on the
exploration problem sorry did I say
exploration before exploit anyway so
here with the exploration problem
um did you ever think about leaving off
uh the extrinsic part of the equation
and just using like the information gain
as a reward like can you structure it
that way would it be different like if
the object of the agent was just to gain
more information about the environment
do you think that it would have
succeeded in um you know climbing the
hill because it would get to a new part
of the of the environment or how do you
think that would
work yeah yeah uh not in this p but it
does um so that other paper I mentioned
the reinforcement through active
influence because it solves it in the
very first task it literally can't be
because of reward we've tested it
without reward as well to confirm this
but you know it hasn't ever experienced
a reward and it's still solves the task
so it's exactly what you're specifying
it's just purely trying to reach all the
parts of the uh the state space uh if
you just left it with expiration what
you tend to find is that it will solve
it for say the first 10 trials while
it's still the peaks of
the Hill are the most kind of
interesting because they have the most
extreme Dynamics with the most variant
um but then after a while uh the top of
the hill is no more interesting than the
bottom of the hill because it's kind of
explored a bit whereas if you've got the
reward and the expiration kind of slowly
transfers from solving it because of
expiration to solving it because it
knows how to get
reward awesome awesome thank you I
didn't see that followup paper I like
I'm going to go read it right after this
I know we need to do it a a
Afterparty active Afterparty with next
paper um but uh Mel and then anyone
else yeah just um what you were
describing with uh like stringing a bow
something like this um I think that was
what really got me excited about active
inference in the free energy principle
in the first place is is the idea that
um with something like a like a a towers
of Hanoi style problem are people
familiar with that uhhuh like you've got
you've got three sticks and and you've
got discs of various sizes on the sticks
and you've got to get them in in a in a
like a ascending order right um and the
idea is that uh the puzzle requires that
you you go backwards before you can go
forwards and if you're just
minimizing or maximizing some function
on a single level um if you've got a
like a a ond
optimization you're you're going to not
be able to solve a problem that requires
that you backtrack in order to make
progress um and something like active
inference the free energy principle
where we've got temporal depth we've got
hierarchical depth of the model um is
really equipped to solve these kind
problems in a way that a lot of
traditional um problem solving
approaches are not I I totally agree and
I think there's a quantitative and a
qualitative so at the quantitative level
there's control policies that we can't
have computers look Beyond some locally
non-favorable states to get around so we
want to do these quantitative policies
that's what this paper is about but at
the qualitative and really the
philosophical level how do we come to
grasp with processes where yeah we're
not always strictly walking a staircase
directly to the top of the mountain or
it might not seem like we can do it at
all initially if we just look and
there's so much there with how we think
about challenges and about exploring one
actual uh link there cuz plue asked
about what would happen if you just let
it go wild on exploring and Alec what
you said is that the learning gets you
to the top pretty quickly because in
that sense it's similar to this model
that also prioritizes reward but then
after getting to the top you spend a lot
of your time learning on the most
extremely variant areas of parameter
space so it's so much like curiosity
driven learning where a lot of times
curiosity driven learning with no reward
or scaffolding it ends up learning
learning learning a ton shocking amounts
but then also spending a lot of time in
the most extreme ranges of space and
that doesn't always just play out like
in the kind of online gutter but even in
the literature we see a lot of the
attention being spent on the extreme
hyperboles and then the middle ground
where it's like yeah it's kind of
balanced and we can work on it together
that is not as extreme of a Viewpoint
and so people spend less learning and
attentional regimes on these kinds of
projects so there's a lot of like
parallels that we can quantitatively
model but also help us think about how
we can say no you're you're just trying
to make me explore the top of the hill I
get it but the flag's on the other side
so I've heard about the other side of
the Hill how are we going to enact a
policy to get us to the flag together
that's a little bit better than your
Hill is worse than my Hill for example
how could these kinds of things be
ported onto like human decision-making
is a cool
area any other questions on one
otherwise let's talk about two a little
bit well just just one quick piece just
picking up on what blur said there I
thought was quite interesting is if
there's this idea of exploring the
environment in different ways but say
there's exploring or Information Gain in
terms of personal preference so for
instance maybe it was a bit more of a
con I like to always feel what it's like
to go slightly up a slope and turn to
the right that feels cool right so then
you have this kind of like it's not
necessarily in it's like an Information
Gain about having
fun so would it like say the car is like
hey I really like to do this type of
things because cars like me like doing
that I know you know if it was a living
animal so it kind of ties into what sort
of exploration of the world and then
What exploration of just being an entity
that likes to do certain things and that
could end up taking you there in another
in another way or together they help
great
Alec yeah I just wanted to comment on
that because this is uh I totally agree
and I think it's one of the most uh
promising kind of directions or
perspectives that active inference gives
and I wrote about this in a in another
paper that I can link afterwards uh of
this notion of I don't really know what
to call it but but goal directed
expiration that you derive from
something like expected free energy and
that means you don't necessarily or it's
just too inefficient just to
have everlasting expiration with no
constraints you know um uh and it's also
too inefficient just to do have
exploitation what you need is some
objective function like expected for
energy or model evidence that contains
these two things so that you're not
selecting actions to just explore or
just to exploit that each action is kind
of shaded with both of these things and
that way you're getting a a expiration
that's um geared towards your goals and
it greatly constrains the type of
exploration you'll be do and I think
from nine you know that also fits with
our kind of experience maybe of of daily
life or maybe not but I think from an
engineering perspective that that's
crucial because in real world task
there's just too much to explore and you
need to prioritize that exploration I
think that's
something yep that's so beautiful and
even another layer is The Ensemble of
mountain cars so now imagine we all see
different things and we don't know the
way to get to the top of the mountain we
don't know the policy we don't even know
what the end point is we don't know if
the one that we can see close by is the
best one or if there's a way better one
way further away and then
everybody is who they are and they all
have their own landscapes and then
through the ensemble's modeling
collectively with or without information
sharing of whatever kind The Ensemble as
we're seeing gets better performance
there isn't just one best policy of
mountain car there are so many different
ways to ascend the mountain and then you
open it up with what the objective
functions and the policies the goals
could be and it really is a a great
space Shannon and then anyone
else hi thanks I was just um thinking
about your Ensemble of of cars here and
comparing this to like flocking
behaviors in birds or even um people who
are foraging together and maybe I was
wondering how so maybe this entire flock
is minimizing its free energy by getting
closer to award which is food but any
individual bird in the flock is just
following local rules about like how
close to fly to other agents or when to
follow them or when to break off and
find a new like go away from the rest of
the flock or drag the flock along with
them and I wonder if every single bird
is having their own little mountain car
model or if there's just one gross model
for the entire flock as a mountain car
finding finding its
food yep well one angle on the foraging
and affordances is Imagine That ensemble
of human foragers but they're not
exactly the same size or they don't have
exactly the same preference or they have
slightly different Visions some people
see closer or further they see color or
they don't see color and so all these
differences are what allow The Ensemble
to explore and exploit especially with
information sharing oh hey I was over
under this tree and I found this but
somebody else wouldn't have found it so
we can all use the Ensemble to take
advantage of our um you know differences
of the nestmates or the flock or
cognitive diversity and then in the
question that you raised about is there
a single uh layer being enacted by the
flock or is there a little mountain car
as you said by each bird so from a
modeler's perspective if it turns out
that we can explain variance about the
bird's trajectory by putting a linear
aggression on it it doesn't say it's
linear aggression that the bird is doing
just that it helped us explain variance
in the world so similarly the low bar
here is that we can use this kind of
model just like we could use another
type of control theory model or action
policy selection model model to explain
variants about the real world and
especially because we see organisms
succeeding in fact it's really the only
ones that we do see this helps us
explain those successful systems as
opposed to like funny little gifts of
you know robot flailing and then whether
there's like one layer that's being
enacted and then the group is purely
epiphenomenal and there's no downward
causation there's no influence of the
group states on the lower level states
there might be some systems like that
there might be other systems where
there's an analytical solution like a
well-defined solution at the bird and
the flock level there might be another
one where it's well defined at one level
but then because of interactions and
emergence it isn't as defined or isn't
defined by the same class of model at a
higher or more coar grained
level any thoughts yeah that's all great
thanks y cool let's look at figure two
so similarly as you did for that um
Mountain car which was like such a
helpful direction to take what can you
tell us about the hopper V2 um or the
inverted pendulum which I don't have
here but those were the two TXS maybe
more on the hopper um or the pendulum
whichever one just what are they about
what Will machine learning people
recognize or know these models as
signify um so
Hopper isn't um it's not expiration
based it's quite a dense reward that you
get so you kind of get rewarded or dis
rewarded for each of your action but uh
it's slightly more High
dimensional
can't it says two dimensional there but
that's just the that's not when I speak
say Dimensions I mean how many
observations it receives um it's more
than two it might be like 16 I'm not
sure uh and it's just generally the
Dynamics so you've got to learn you know
you've got maybe four actions which are
real value numbers between minus 4 and
four you've got to learn how that
changes 16 variables over the course of
your however long you're planning so
it's it's a much harder task to learn um
so I guess that's why it was um included
in in this just that it's generally
valid is a bit of a hard task in the
machine learning commun cool and so what
is happening in figure two what can we
say how is it different than ddpg and
what actually is ddpg for
reference ddpg is uh the so acronyms and
deep deterministic policy gradients um
so what is that one doing and then what
is active inference doing that different
that maybe enables it to have such
better
performance um so what is uh ddpg doing
so it's just a it's a model 3
reinforcement learning algorithm so you
have a policy that maps from states to
actions and you essentially do a load of
maths from something like Bowman
equation to get to
um an update for your um policy
parameters um the reason that it's doing
so much better the reason that
modelbased reinforcement learning in
general does so much better um is
because it's essentially it's a planning
algorithm so
um what's the best way to describe this
yeah
um due to the fact it's model based it
can learn from every
single um bit of data that it receives
so that is in terms of each state
transition and as well as the reward
signals um whereas this model 3
reinforcement learning is is just simply
learning from that single bit of
information they gets at each time step
which is uh um the corresponding reward
or 32 bits or what however your rewards
work ex thinked um so I mean eventually
ddpg after enough EPO would probably
asent it around or higher than um model
based that's a kind of
General uh pattern you get with model
base and model 3 reinforcement learning
model base is far more sample efficient
uh but model 3 takes a hell of a lot
more samples but is um ASM tootes gets
you know levels out at a higher
reward let me also add a layer there um
with a few other aspects from machine
learning and the idea of the ruggedness
of the landscape so if you're doing this
task which was described as a dense task
another way of thinking about these is
you're trying to keep something upright
so it's like very obvious if you're
succeeding or failing and in the big
landscape there's really easy to tell
differences between succeeding and
failing that being said policy planning
especially when you have four variables
of control that are projecting out to
like 16 potentially nonlinear connected
outcomes when you're trying to do that
there may be many strategic mappings
there might be many policies that help
you keep the pendulum up like for
example going a little bit Back in Forth
with a certain speed or you can go a
little further with a different Rhythm
so there might be a many many different
ways even for a single joint of control
many policy sequences Through Time many
learned relationships that help you stay
in that yes no area now if you have a
model-free reinforcement learner it
means it's learning basically the raw
connection it's model-free socalled
between the reward and the policy and so
it may spend a lot of its time exploring
locally a policy because it's like in
the spotlight it's working and then it
goes to a slightly different area it's
not working where do we go from outside
of the spotlight it's all dark no idea
model free with the Deep generative
model it's not like this Spotlight in or
out reinforcement it's like we're
learning these intrinsic relationships
which actually helps us get a grasp of
the maps that are going to guide us to
search on the territory a little bit
more exhaustively but then that part at
the end which was so interesting that
the model fre sometimes gets to higher
final performance in some context that
can be because a truly model-free search
can result in some wacky combination
that wouldn't have NE necessarily been
approached that it just uniquely
potentially not in a resilient way but
it uniquely allows some performance on a
task and so that reminds me of like the
evolutionary computation where it its
goal will be to travel distance and then
some will actually go down the walking
Road and those start slow but they could
walk forever and then other ones just
like fall and so it's kind of like
hacking to get over um a barrier without
necessarily uh a deeper understanding of
the ecology because it's so blindly
pursuing just performance so I know
there's a lot of stuff there but this is
like really an illustrative example and
it does highlight a lot of the
differences between the model free
performance and the state-of-the-art in
that as well as what potentially active
inference could
bring any thoughts on to now we'll just
have some general areas basically the
first area was implications I know we've
probably talked about some of them but
three areas that I thought about were
like robotics resources and allocation
and then rugged Landscapes this one
probably in the southwest um so any
thoughts on these I think we've almost
touched on few related ideas but if
anyone wants to like speak to one of
these areas of possible implication
whether they do they don't see what an
implication could be or what would
another domain of implication be um yeah
Alec go
ahead so
um I also am becoming interested and so
are some other people in um whether some
so I'm very invested in this idea of
kind of a Bas and brain and
um as active inference kind of as FES
but whether some of these ideas from Bas
and machine learning that are used in
this paper so stuff like
amortization um might also be employed
in nervous systems um so you know we've
had a few very very uh big proposals for
how the brain might Implement Bing infl
stuff like population coding predictor
coding uh the processor that's most
commonly associated with fact of
inference in this terms of message
passing but it might also be uh you know
this amortization is also um another
real possibility of how the brain
implements some type of um inflence so I
think it could have implications for
understanding neur
science wow did not expect that message
passing and predictive processing
predictive coding type models can be
understood alongside amortization model
models as an alternate implementation or
mechanism of basian brain as a specific
testable hypothesis so this is where the
rubber hits the road with the modeling
and with showing the Deep mathematical
isomorphisms between these different
kinds of relationships like there might
be some paper I'm sure there is where
like message passing is equivalent to
basian networks and then that allows us
to bridge two big areas of literature
and so if we do a lot of Investigation
in in brain and then we find out wait
there's actually multiple ways that that
could be implemented in different
systems whether that's through message
passing so maybe that's more applicable
to a computer network maybe it's also
going to be implemented by policy
planning ensembles so then whoa what
else is doing this kind of basian like
processing so there's so many cool
directions there great topic because
also robotics or at least the question
of implementation of action and
selection of policy and from sensors
with actuators resources in terms of
informational attentional whatever they
may be and then rugged Landscapes is
just that's everything that is policy
selection under uncertainty for any kind
of system that wants to stay alive let's
go oh sorry Sasha or blue oh see you
later blue oh wait Sasha out blue please
thank
you wait muted but yeah go ahead uh so I
just I had the same reaction that you
did like basing brain amortization like
wow I just was wondering uh Alec if you
could maybe just unpack that like in a
very simple way or elaborate more on on
that yeah uh sure so
um the best way so I mean amortization
um as it's realized in stuff like
variational cers but also other schemes
um we can like maybe discuss a bit more
to get what defines amortization are
just an instance a way of learning a g
model and well more precisely doing
inference uh the key defining features
for me although I don't think this is
ever been properly defined in the
literature is this notion of having an
encoder um how that would play out in
the
brain um how it could play out in the
brain is just kind of a um a feed
forward mapping um feed forward part of
say the visual cortex that maps from
some data or a lower part in the
hierarchy to some posterior parameters
higher up uh in the hierarchy and when
you have stuff like um population coding
or predictive coding there's not this
notion of quickly in a fe forward manner
mapping from data to parameters you've
got this kind of iterative procedure
that slowly um and um sequentially
updates the beliefs those posterior
beliefs based on the data based on some
learning so it's another um route
towards B INF it's far far more fast and
doesn't require recurrent processing and
that kind of speaks well with some
things we know about the brain it's not
all the brain the brain definitely does
have Rec of processing but a lot can be
done in in a kind of Fe forward manner
very quickly uh and and the second thing
is that um the parameters that you're
optimizing of the encoder are optimized
um over the entire data set whereas in
some like predictive coding it's
optimized individually the posterior
parameters um of your beliefs optimized
uh based on the current data point uh
and I think that has
some that might speak to some of the
generalization capabilities of Bas
inflence um and that's something that
we're looking at at moment so more
obious I hope that kind of answers your
question R bit no definitely thank you
so much totally epic to connect that
feed forward encoder model to the
machine learning um side so so instead
of doing like a back and forth
expectation maximization where you're um
just updating back and forth or
especially a uh like a back propagation
type thing where there's very very
complex interactions about how
parameters are trained this allows us to
kind of train on the Fly and just learn
as we go now to the second point which
is the usage of the entire data set
versus Point by point this is like we're
learning on the fly but um we're
learning on the fly in the state space
that we want to be learning about with
respect to the entire data set that we
have access to which is a little bit
different than like you're kind of
trailing your finger along a Time series
and then you're updating based upon that
data point and what you believe and what
you've recently seen that's like a kind
of Point bypo way to use a whole data
set to update parameters versus this
variational approach which actually
enables like almost a simultaneous
utilization of the entire State space
I'm not sure if that's totally correct
but those are just two parts that hit me
about the two sides that you mentioned
Alec Stephen and then anyone
else so I've not heard of this
amortization so it's quite interesting
it's it's almost like an reverse then is
it it's like you you'd have a a big
complex space of knowing and you quickly
discount stuff and the process is about
disc scouting away rather than building
up the model is that is that kind of the
the
idea uh I'm not sure if I've understand
understood exactly what you're at but
for my from I'm not sure if it if it is
but maybe we could get into that a bit
more how would you define Alec how would
you define amortized inference like we
see it here in the paper but how would
you define it you mentioned some
benefits we've talked about them a
little bit but like in this kind of new
way of thinking about it what what does
it mean or what would it mean for the
brain to do it or what happened
programmatically I mean so this is what
I was getting earlier it doesn't really
have a a clear definition um I I try and
Define in two ways one is how it's
generally used if you see amortized
inference in um machine learning uh
you're generally you should think of a
encoder Network so you've got a neural
network it takes in your data and it
will output literal values for your
parameters that would normally and those
parameters are the ones that would
normally be optimized in traditional
variational methods here it's just um
they're just spat out by the network um
and then you have some other um learning
method which which updates that en code
for you and also your generative model
but um in terms of what amortization
actually means going back to the word I
think derives from economics um I think
it's this idea that you come to the
second point that I made where uh you're
sharing the parameters of that encoder
across all of your data so you're
amortizing the cost of inference um is
how I think about it I could be I could
be very wrong um so that just means you
you kind of
don't reset with um each new observation
or you're not trying to optimize with
respect to um each new observation and
then kind of discarding the information
you're just sharing that encoder um the
the encoder which is the relationship
between the data and the parameters
across uh your entire lifetime so you're
amortizing the cost of infant is how I
think about it so a better
quote so is it like is it like you so as
opposed to just discounting data it's
discounting ways of chunking up the data
or ways of analyzing it if that makes
sense like you could have lots of
different models and they say okay I'm
going to apply them in a more efficient
way over time as you start infer it's
almost infering what models should be
deployed is that the kind of idea and
you start to take away the models which
are less useful in a way I guess you
could another kind
of people sometimes refer to it as
learning to infer so in which might be
what you're getting at um so in normal
inference you're just doing inference
but here you're
learning how to do inference so the
learning um yeah so maybe that was what
you're getting up with your kind of mod
selection tape cool thanks yeah that
that that makes sense I don't know but
I'm trying to find my way through
there's a few Dimensions so it's really
helpful to unpack it there's the
learning how to learn there's that meta
learning element but also this is really
important that in the paper is the
number of parameters remains constant
with respect to the size of the data so
if I'm trying to estimate the mean and
the variance of a normal distribution I
know that I want to squeeze down
whatever data set I have into two
numbers
and so if I have three numbers coming in
the pipeline I still want a mean and a
variance if I want a billion numbers to
come in the pipeline I still I want mean
variance and so it turns out that by
knowing and by specifying ahead of time
that you know exactly the size of the
outcome it allows you to uh scale a lot
better because you can know that no
matter what you're going to put in on
the inside it's going to be able to be
distilled down very rapidly whereas
another method that results okay well we
put a data set and then we find out how
many principal components explain it
best that might computationally scale in
a way that is very um disadvantageous
with respect to the size of the data
whereas this method can um do that and
then as a sort of correr there it's
happening through a single forward pass
of a network which can be AB initio sort
of like denovo setting it up from the
beginning and or updated in a learning
fashion and so there's there's a few
dimensions and Alec really look forward
to you know seeing what you continue to
do with the amortized inference seeing
as that concept becomes a bit more
formalized because this seems like
really powerful and then if it also
turns out that it's an implementation of
basian Statistics or basian brain then
it just Taps into the entire message
passing compute graph um basian NET
Framework which already has been the um
most helpful for machine learning in a
lot of other areas too
very very cool
so I guess in the next steps which is
really I guess the last thing that we'll
talk about for the last few minutes just
thought of a few areas to go into for
Next Step so Alec definitely you take
the first pass but the areas could be
like computationally what does that mean
Hardware software from a math
perspective what could be analytically
shown or what relationships would be
good to know um from an applications
perspective what robots need this kind
of software update
and then just educationally how do we
come to you know control our attention
so that we understand these Concepts as
well or what did you start working on
after this paper I guess it was yeah no
worries no worries I was I wasn't yeah
but I guess you did this one or where
are you at now steps are um I guess on
this line of thinking that the um this
line of work the stuff that I'm still
thinking about is what was mentioned
right at the beginning which is the
balance of uh exploitation and
exploration and whether the active
influence perspective provides you um
anything in
practice um because you know we've got
this nice objective functional expected
for energy uh and we can optimize
actions with respect to it and it does
contain exporation exploitation and it
motivates expiration and exploitation
from first phasing principles but in
practice you're going to be in any model
you're going to be uh fine-tuning those
um the the balance between those um
you've got a bit more of leeway to do it
because now you can um change the shape
of your PRI beliefs for instance uh and
change a few other parameters that are
going to lead to that playoff rather
than just having some scal of weight
that defines them so some of the stuff
that I've been looking at is yeah
learning prior beliefs in order to
facilitate exploration exploitation um
because I think the the to summarize
that yeah the balance between
exploration exploitation is is probably
one of the big unsolved questions in um
control reinforcement learning
Neuroscience Etc um and for making these
machines work um as well as we'd like
them to uh and active influence offers a
new route to try to solve that I don't
think it has been solved
awesome that's really exciting there's
just so many aspects to the control
theory question when there's a lot of
solutions that could work and maybe it's
even unclear what it would look like to
work especially as we think about some
of these systems that go beyond um the
merely just keep a pendulum standing but
what if it's give someone a massage well
that's a little bit of a different
question it's relational or how are you
going to exercise in a way that's
comfortable for you these are control
theory questions that are literally
about action sequences and so when we
start thinking about how we're going to
apply it to different systems having a
framework that is at least moving in
this direction of what you said is like
with the reconsidering the explore
exploit by adding things like
reconsidering the shape of your prior so
how can you step into a framework where
the explore exploit is a dimension that
could be calculated or described or kind
of summarized but isn't simply the
underlying framework of the model we're
going to get exploratory Behavior we're
going to get so-called exploitative or
narrowly searching behavior that is not
being ruled out by what we're discussing
we're talking about another way that
optimization could proceed that doesn't
use simply the explore versus exploit um
or the coefficient waiting of these two
through time or statically to um outline
its whole learning approach so Stephen
first and then anyone else if they want
to give any like last thoughts but this
has been a great conversation so even
than anyone
else I mean also if you go into the real
world environment you've got this
explore exploit situation but in high
stake situations you've also got um like
they often talk about risk mitigation
versus gain optimization if you're in a
kind of um a conflict or you know a
legal situation because it may be that
it's a question of you know which is in
a way gain optimization is a bit like an
explo exp it but it depends which way
you're going it could be an information
game but whatever you're you're trying
to do those two two aspects sort of come
into play depending on the state of the
of the situation you know so you know
explore exploit is less relevant when
you're standing on the edge of a cliff
playing a game you know because it's
like there's a risk mitigation issue so
anyway I thought that might be
interesting I just thought about you
know doing learning action policy but if
you're learning an action policy where
you could die if you're rock climbing or
something it's going to change how you
learn and so when you're trying to
minimize risk versus failure attempt or
minimize the number of opportunities you
have to see it successfully performed or
you can only infer it by observing it
these things may contain a ton of
information in terms of how real systems
learn where failure is not an option Mel
and then anyone else who wants to close
it
out yeah sorry if this is I guess a a
sort of an ignorant question but I I
thought some of like the beauty of these
act inference and FP approaches is is
that they're sort of doing a a kind of
like multi-level Dynamic aoms razor type
thing so they're they're maximizing
predictability well well also kind of
minimizing the complexity of of what
they're doing
and so I guess what I don't quite
understand is how the amortization of
inference process works but if you're
fixing the params doesn't that kind of
uh constrain the ability of of these
approaches to to do that kind of aroms
Razor type type
uh um not really because the parameters
of your encoder aren't the parameters
that you're they're not the free energy
parameters they're mapping to the free
energy parameters so you could map you
know to uh you know fre just says that
you've got to maximize yeah the accuracy
or the likelihood while minimizing um
the complexity so as long as your
encoder maps to the part of Lea stat
that is maximally uh accurate and also
minimally complex then you're still
minimizing um complexity while
maximizing accuracy uh and then
obviously there's what we haven't
discussed is the learning schemes for so
the way you learn your encoded
parameters is so that they out but
something that does conform to minimal
variation yes okay so you're not
actually
constraining you're not actually placing
like additional constraints on on the
parameter of the actual not on the
parameters of the encoder on the output
of the encoder
yeah I guess that's a good point uh so
the the encod the I guess a problem of
armatization is that um the encoder is
kind of not part you shouldn't think of
it as part of your generative model it's
just almost like a a tool that can
um map to the belief space of your
generative model
um yeah just
so just on a closing note there that
really returns us this dual
instrumentalism with rappers and rappers
and is it what the system is doing or is
it how we're looking at it these
questions are very rich and so it's a
great conversation really thanks
everyone for participating this was such
a helpful discussion and I think
definitely while R listening we'll all
pick out some questions for ourselves to
follow up on and some curious things to
learn about because there are so many
good ideas brought up so if people who
are on live if they check their calendar
event they will see a feedback form
which would be helpful and anyone else
who's listening or watching please
provide us with feedback suggestions or
questions but other than that just um
stay in touch and everyone awesome work
for this helpful discussion and we'll
see you soon